bonjour à tous
il est l'heure de parlement hebdo une
émission politique et parlementaire que
j'ai le plaisir d'animer avec mickaël
zeze bonjour bijoux et visant 45 minutes
pour décortiquer toutes l'actualité
politique et parlementaire et à la une
cette semaine la loi elle conneries sur
la réforme du travail toujours très
contestée entre 170 mille six cent mille
personnes ont manifesté dans toute la
france jeudi en marge des cortèges de
violents affrontements ont eu lieu entre
casseurs et forces de l'ordre à paris
rennes marseille ou nantes forte
amélioration sur le front économique la
croissance repart autre bonne nouvelle
cette semaine la baisse du chômage
soixante mille demandeurs d'emploi au
mois en mars notre action porte ses
fruits déclare le ministre des finances
ça va mieux a déclaré françois hollande
à la télévision ils ont donc voulu
martelé ce message une vingtaine de
ministres s'est réuni lundi à paris
c'est et au la gauche une initiative
lancée par stéphane le foll pour
défendre le bilan du chef de l'état
alors ça va mieux on demandera d'autres
invités qui commentera toute l'actualité
de cette semaine luc carvounas
bonjourbonjour sénateur maire
d'alfortville où vous allez commenter
tombe toute cette actualité et on va
donc commencer par ceux qui a marqué ce
début de semaine c'est ce cri du coeur
et au la gauche
et vous le savez on n'est jamais mieux
servi que par soi même et donc les
arrivées fidèles de françois hollande
étaient réunis lors d'un meeting à paris
objectif défendre le bilan du
quinquennat
5 jean baptiste daoulas et au la gauche
c'est l'expression pas très courante
choisi par stéphane le foll pour
défendre la politique de françois
hollande
c'était une interpellation que si c'est
à dire mais on est critiqué tout le
temps critiqué mais et où regarder quand
même ce qu'on a fait et comme l'adage
veut que l'on n'est jamais aussi bien
servi que par soi même
ce sont une vingtaine d'actuels et
anciens ministres de françois hollande
qui se charge de défendre le bilan du
président avec des éléments de langage
soigneusement préparés sur le plan
économique les choses vont mieux
la france va mieux la france va mieux
qu'elle ne le pensait le même un élément
de langage pour rassurer les français et
un autre pour mettre en garde ceux qui
comme emmanuel macron veulent dépasser
le clivage gauche droite parce que la
réalité c'est que la gauche et la droite
c'est pas pareil à droite et la gauche
n'est pas la même chose emmanuel macron
est absent mais les principaux ministres
sont là pour énumérer les mesures prises
depuis 2012 retraite à 60 ans prime
d'activité mariage pour tous le meeting
prend alors des airs de thérapie de
groupe pour faire croire à 2017 comme
femme ministre de gauche je veux aussi
vous dire que moi je n'ai pas renoncé à
la victoire en 2017
j'appelle faut que l'on apprenne les
frondeurs à ne pas se tromper de temps
il n'y a personne à gauche qui doit
vouloir faire taire la cause
le meeting a galvanisé les partisans de
françois hollande
mais il n'a pas rassemblé au delà de la
majorité les frondeurs
europe ecologie les verts et le parti
communiste ont critiqué l'opération par
le cas vous signez vous même ce vendredi
dans le monde une tribune avec 23
parlementaire en somme c'est un soutien
à françois hollande
ça y est c'est parti on a un soutien à
françois hollande j'espère que nous
sommes tous majorité présidentielle oui
oui bien sûr il ya toujours les
collègues que l'on qualifie de frondeurs
depuis le début de ce quinquennat
écoutez moi c'est aux opérations et aux
la gauche si elle peut être utile mettre
une pièce de plus dans la machine de la
compréhension vis-à-vis de vos
concitoyens tant mieux je pense
sincèrement que c'est pas le rôle des
ministres de faire ça mais est-ce que ça
sert ce genre d'initiative si le plus
une méthode coué ou non ça peut toujours
servir d'un moment où on en parle de ce
qu'on a fait donc tout ce qui peut
servir à rappeler bilan c'est utile mais
est ce que c'est le rôle des ministres
de le faire je crois pas pourquoi c'est
parce que c'est le job du parti
socialiste et je crois que les français
qui nous observent qui attendent
justement que les résultats soient de
plus en plus positif
ils attendent davis qui soit au travail
et non pas dans la peau qu'ils auraient
tort de se réunir comme ça à part girafe
à ces médecines je pense que vous l'avez
dit mikel ça mais ce sont les amis
historiques de france hollande mais là
aussi j'avais cru comprendre que nous
étions tous hollandais donc c'est le
mouvement répondre à gauche de 2011 qui
propose la famille mal voilà de stéphane
le foll qui prend aujourd'hui l'essor de
où la gauche donc on comprend que c'est
la préparation de la candidature
j'imagine de de françois hollande à
l'élection présidentielle il faut quand
même vous critiquer le fait que ce soit
les ministres aujourd'hui oui parce que
je vous en ai assez dangereux
les ministres il faut qu'ils soient à
leurs tâches sont à 100% ce qu'ils
doivent faire le job de l'explication
dans le texte et les parlementaires
j'en fais partie vous l'avez dit j'ai
signé une tribune et c'est le parti
socialiste donc l'alliance ne sont pas
alors durement faut faire aussi
attention à l'image que ça renvoie parce
que quand on est dans ce genre
d'initiative faut pas se tromper
et si ça renvoie l'image d'un d'entre
eux soit avec des élus et des
collaborateurs d'élus c'est le cas un
peu beaucoup comme un oui il faut dire
les choses donc je ne suis pas sûr tout
ça participe au delà de ce qu'on imagine
que ce serait donc c'est bien mais c'est
une expérience qui peut être utile mais
encore une fois je veux que cette
énergie soit plus consacré dans le parti
socialiste dont je suis secrétaire
national ou tôt jean-christophe
cambadélis autour de la belle alliance
populaire
pourquoi je dis ça parce que je vois
maintenant que patrick kanner veut faire
un héros la gauche à lille que les amis
de martine aubry 10 en plus ça va se
faire sans nous donc merci du retient
plusieurs initiatives qui ont été
lancées avouera-t-il a belle allure sur
une journée d'initiatives dans les
régions il y en a qu'une
ses seuls initiés par jean christophe
cambadélis celle de la belle alliance
populaire
moi je le souhaite sur sur la vie des
autres non je dise non non je ne
souhaite pas non c'est très bien que ça
a été encore une fois est d'ailleurs moi
je participe à cela dans la tribune
initiée ici par ma collègue et ami
frédérique espagnac cette date-là
non bon ça a été utile on en a parlé ce
a permis de rappeler le bilan jusque
très bien le petit reportage à témoigner
mais encore une fois
moi je suis maire d'alfortville en mai
habitants ils disent tous les jours bon
bah c'est très bien c'est très bien mais
on veut que les ministres soient
justement à leur charge il ya comme
macron lorsque nous a même sens juste
avant par emmanuel macron un grand
absent de la gauche était manuel valls
qui n'était pas là il n'est pas
comptable du bilan du gouvernement
il est le chef du gouvernement c'est lui
qui me l'a écouté il y avait dans son
calendrier dans son agenda parlementaire
pardon je suis pas son chef de cabinet
proche de manuel valls mais je dirais de
comptable de tout mais pas de son agenda
quand même en tous les cas
l'initiative a été initiée par stéphane
le foll il y avait beaucoup de mini
sadate qu'elles valent sens mal je
constate que je revienne le drian n'y
était pas que bernard cazeneuve n'était
pas que manuel valls n'était pas qui
mena le maquereau qui a été mal cité
manuellement par les manuels mac on va
en parler puisque c'est un ministre qui
fait particulièrement parler de lui en
ce moment
il multiplie les déplacements les
petites phrases qui me motive c'est de
façonner l'avenir de mon pays at il dit
à un journal allemand
alors emmanuel macron qui promet une
nouvelle offre pour 2017 leur carte luc
carvounas elle qui sait ce qu'il doit
clarifier sa position
c'est lui le dire moi je vous constate
que on marche a débuté à amiens et qui
est déjà en marge à paris et visiblement
donc
faut faire extrêmement attention je
pense que emmanuel macron est un vrai
produit l'ascenseur républicain c'est
une cette année c'est ça l'esprit
brillant
qu'est ce qu'il veut faire il veut être
j'imagine candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je croyais oui je le
pense
il faut qu'il soit clair il n'organise
pas un mouvement comme celui là sans
avoir l'idée peut-être d'être candidat
après j'ai entendu qu'il était loyal à
françois vous savez je vous dois rester
ministre ou pas mais c'est pas à moi de
le dire
vous avez un dieu personnel donc là moi
de le dire mais elle va le dis que c'est
la créature de françois hollande
vainqueur aisé
on saura dans quelques semaines très
rapidement s'il est candidat ou pas
parce que j'imagine que si c'est son
architecture est ce qu'ils prévoient de
ça il quittera le gouvernement mais en
même temps je trouverais ça dommage
qu'il quitte le gouvernement parce que
c'est quelqu'un de brillant et que vous
voyez ce qui manque c'est cette notion
du collectif et pourquoi ça manque
ben parce qu'on va trop vite dans une
carrière politique au congrès quelques
étapes
l'étape du rapport à la fidélité l'étape
à la construction politique à la famille
qui vous a permis et donc d'être là où
vous êtes
il va à mon sens dans ce qui est mon adn
à moi trop vite parce que moi j'ai
appris ce que c'était a étant un enfant
ici une famille prolétaires l'ascenseur
républicain je les prie aussi mais j'ai
appris aussi ce qu'étaient les codes en
politique notamment le rapport à la
fidélité et je trouve ça très étrange
peu celui qui vous a construit en
l'occurrence françois hollande a
construit emmanuel macron certains même
accusé que c'était le fait du prince qui
l'avait nommé ministre
aujourd'hui de le voir pousser des ailes
vers un autre avenir faut juste faire
attention qu'il ne vienne pas icare on
passe à mardi mardi le chômage était à
la une
forte baisse du chômage en mars 2016
mois 1,7 pour cent soit soixante mille
demandeurs d'emploi en moins du jamais
vu depuis 16 ans de bons résultats
saluée par la ministre du travail
ecoutez-la moins soixante mille c'est la
meilleure baisse mensuelle depuis 2000
voilà donc depuis 16 ans et j'ai
l'habitude vous le savez pour ceux qui
me suivent dans chacun de ces annonces
des chiffres mensuels du chômage
j'ai toujours l'habitude de rappeler et
tous les services statistiques ne disent
également qu'il faut regarder les choses
en tendant sur les trois derniers mois
là la tendance allait très clair c'est
moins cinquante mille demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie à sur les trois
derniers mois
donc non la baisse n'est pas timide la
baisse est importante et c'est une bonne
nouvelle
luc carvounas on entend des mirabelles
comme réel parle de tendance on voit là
ça a baissé au mois de mars à remonter
au mois de février
on peut pas vraiment parler d'une baisse
continue de la courbe du chômage oui
mais en boîte vocale est réaliste moi je
fais partie de ceux qui depuis le début
de ce quinquennat même dans les pires
difficultés je dis toujours vous allez
voir les réformes structurelles posée
par françois hollande et manuel valls
vont porter leurs fruits je l' ai
toujours dit il croyait pour la version
d'ici la fin de la bien sûr billy
tendance les plantes macroéconomique
c'est pas vrai qu'il dit ce sont tous
les experts elles sont là elles le
prouvent
mais en même temps je me souviens d'un
échange de vues avec un sourire depuis
donc illégal un nom déjà
dave même si ça va aller mieux pour 37
pression les français parce que ça va
arriver tard auront du mal à le voir
voir ne verront pas du tout doux tout la
nécessité de cette pédagogie a martelé
et ça c'est le job du parlementaire que
je suis et pourquoi le nouveau président
et comment nous présidons il est le chef
de l'état le chef des armées
il doit être à l'initiative de
l'organisation de la politique
gouvernementale ce qui fait très bien
voilà je pense que
le président de la république a été
peut-être mal conseiller en
communication c'est pas à lui de dire ça
va mieux lui il est dans l'action ce
qu'ils doivent dire ça va mieux ce sont
les français et ce sont les français
parce que nous les parlementaires encore
une fois plutôt que de regarder notre
nombril ou de tirer un peu la couverture
sur nous-mêmes comme le font certains
dans la majorité présidentielle
nous sommes sur le terrain moi je disais
je suis maire d'alfortville sur le
terrain en permanence je confronté à la
mort est elle en permanence et donc ça
c'est notre travail et nous et nous
notre travail c'est d'être derrière
président de la république est de faire
en sorte de recul qui soit demain
j'espère réélu le chômage baisse la
croissance repart avant les as tout à
l'heure tout est réuni pour que françois
hollande puis se représenter en 2017
moi j'ai toujours dit écoutez sous la
vème république le président sortant
et le candidat légitime après nous avons
aussi conditionné sa candidature quand
même à la dallas conditionné alors oui
oui je vous dire depuis maintenant
quelques heures quelques jours on a
moins soixante mille chômeurs de moins
et j'entendais ce matin sur une chaîne
concurrente thomas piketty qui vient
nous dire au pape a passé soixante mille
c'est très bien mais on a quand même 658
chômeurs de plus sur le quinquennat
alors il faut faire quoi finalement
toujours dire que ça va pas donc oui on
le dit ça va mieux de willich oui ça va
mieux
oui les français ne voient pas que ça va
mieux et oui il faut utiliser tous les
relais locaux que nous sommes nous les
maires les premiers guichets
républicains pour expliquer pourquoi ça
va mieux et moi je le vois dans mon
bureau quand les petites tpe viennent me
voir monsieur le maire le carré comment
il repart donc il faut qu'on soit dans 7
dans cette énergie là et moi je suis
persuadé que la courbe du chômage
meriem comrie d'une miss très courageuse
qui dit que la courbe est une tendance
eh ben on va faire en sorte avec
françois hollande et manuel valls
emmanuel macron que la tendance
s'accélère alors autres temps forts de
l'actualité parlementaire c'est la
réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature voté conforme par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat qui
pourrait ouvrir la voie à la tenue d'un
congrès le ministre de la justice
il tient mais la majorité des trois
cinquièmes des parlementaires semble
quasiment impossible à trouver
jean baptiste daoulas l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le texte à un vote de
l'assemblée conforme à celui du sénat
françois hollande est désormais libre de
convoquer un congrès sur la réforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
libre sauf que l'opposition des députés
les républicains l'empêchent d'atteindre
la barre des trois cinquièmes nécessaire
pour valider la réforme
le congrès semble donc compromis même si
le ministre de la justice espère encore
convaincre quelques députés de droite
il ya aussi des parlementaires
qui ont dit je pense à georges fenech
par exemple secrétaire justice du
républicain kim à l'occasion beaucoup
dit pendant les débats en commission son
attachement à l'indépendance de la
magistrature
moi je fais appel à la conviction je
demande que les postures sont oubliées
mais les députés les républicains ne
semblent pas prêts à faire de cadeaux
ils dénoncent une réforme a minima qui
ne changerait rien depuis 2008 le
gouvernement suit déjà les avis du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour les nominations au parquet moi
j'appelle de mes voeux une plus forte
une réelle indépendance de la justice
encore une fois c'est ça va au delà
d'une simple mesure technique qui nous
est proposé et qui est très en retrait
du projet initial qui avait voulu
président de la république donc tout
cela me paraît les dans la précipitation
ne touche pas la constitution
on touche je dirais à la caution que
d'une main tremblante et lin
manifestement on n'est pas danger dans
un contexte qui permet de le faire c'est
donc désormais un bras de fer qui va
s'engager entre la majorité et
l'opposition
quitte à prendre l'opinion publique à
témoin je crois qu'ils montrent que si
on fait le calcul quarantaine de voir il
appartient au président de la république
de juger s'il peut prendre le risque
d'aller à versailles a n'était pas
certaine de gagner ou si le fait de
perdre par exemple nous permettrait de
mettre la droite devant ses
responsabilités sur la question de
l'indépendance du parquet le président
du sénat gérard larcher a déjà indiqué
hier qu'il était hostile à une
convocation du congrès le carbonate vous
croyez possible la tenue d'un congrès
sur la réforme du csm tous les cas elle
céderait formelle a été votée dans les
deux chambres au parlement après pour le
congrès s'était bien dit il faut les 3 5
et moi je vais vous dire
moi je souhaite qu'on y aille au congrès
faut tenter le coup faut qu'on lirait au
congrès parce que franchement de
comparable d'indépendance de la justice
du fait que le csm donne son avis sur la
nomination des magistrats et là on est
en train de nous dire la droite qui
était une année de l'élection
présidentielle qui nous fait la
ritournelle c'est pas assez faut
regarder dans ça suffit de réformes que
jean-jacques sur quoi ça résume en
marche et le garde des sceaux a eu
raison mon ami on voit sa raison il faut
aller au congrès il faut que le
président la république comme il la
vidéo aux françaises et aux français
réunissent le congrès chacun prendra une
bonne fois pour toutes ses
responsabilités et pas nous faire la
petite leçon comme au moment de la
déchéance de nationalité
chacun prendra ses responsabilités vous
voudrez peut-être pas de majorité de
chaque l'échec du congrès peu importe on
verra rey à cause de qui sera l'échec -
selon vous m'interrogez c'est mon
souhait voilà je ne souhaite pas comme
j'aurais aimé s'il m'avait interrogé il
ya quelques années
koné même au congrès sur le vote des
étrangers aux élections plié chacun doit
prendre ses responsabilités c'est ça
aussi le parlement s'est pas plus de 900
parlementaires réfugiés vers la décision
d'un seul homme qui est le chef de
l'état en congrès en conscience en
conscience politique
chacun devra s'exprimer alors on va
passer au mercredi sur un tout autre
sujet de les sénateurs s'intéresser aux
lanceurs d'alerté
mais vous savez en ce moment il ya de
nombreux pots cei et de procès notamment
de luxe l'x c'est le cdh a pendant ce
temps là qui se penche sur le statut de
ce qu'on appelle ses lanceurs d'alert
comment mieux les protéger tout en
défendant le secret des affaires cette
drôle de problème et les explications
sont signés bouillir sociaux nous
revient dans un instant ses lanceurs d
alerte font un travail utile pour la
communauté internationale ils prennent
des risques
il doit donc être protégé cette
intention énoncés dès la révélation de
la sphère des panamas papers devrait se
traduire dans la loi le texte sur la
république numérique examiné par le
sénat possède un amendement créant un
statut pour les lanceurs d alerte
informatique
il serait protégé des poursuites
judiciaires en cas de divulgation de
failles d'un réseau aux autorités
concernées
depuis 2007 six lois tente de définir ce
statut aujourd'hui seules les personnes
révélant des informations sur des
dangers sanitaires ou environnementaux
bénéficient d'une protection solide
la loi anti corruption des entreprises
porté par michel sapin contient des
dispositions en faveur des lanceurs
d'alert le ministre des finances
souhaite les protéger contre les
représailles en leur accordant un
dédommagement financier et en prenant en
charge leurs éventuels frais de justice
le vote de la directive européenne sur
le secret des affaires pourraient
contrarier ce projet elle donne des
moyens juridiques supplémentaires aux
entreprises pour poursuivre tous les
acteurs journalistes ou citoyens
révélant des informations
confidentielles
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ses lanceurs
d'alain michel sapin par exemple vous
rémunérez c'est leur soeur dallaire pour
qu'ils aient un vrai statut final mais
il a raison mais je crois même qu'il a
annoncé que dans la loi sapin de et
regarderai à renforcer justement
le statut des lanceurs dallaire faut
faire extrêmement attention là encore
quand on entend directive européenne
surtout cette défiance sur une forme
d'élite qui chapote finalement notre vie
quotidienne en france quitterait repris
par les populistes et marine le pen la
première et jean luc mélenchon en 2d moi
je dis attention après panama peppers
qui a montré une grande liste à la
prévert où il ya des politiques des
sportifs des gens du monde de
l'entreprise si dame en quoi une caste
une élite qui au dessus de toutes les
lois qui finalement les s'entendent plus
tous pourris si eux mêmes la la
mondialisation est passée par là moi je
souhaite que la france et le président
de la république raison de la firme et
de le marteler joue sur ce sujet là
cette question et c'est tout à notre
honneur à la france à la république
le fait de devoir laisser comme seul
message où il est le sort des alertes
doivent être protégés oui on doit
renforcer toutes celles et tous ceux qui
finalement sans quoi améliorent la vie
démocratique de nos pays et de la france
en particulier
en face à l'actualité française c'est un
géant français qui voit rouge la dette
d'edf ne cesse de gonfler l'entreprise
doit-elle continuer d'investir
auditionné par les sénateurs le pdg
d'edf jean bernard lévy s'est montré
serein
jordan qu'un allonger la durée de vie
des centrales existantes 51 milliards
d'euros
le p r dink l'épaule en grande bretagne
16 milliards de projets ambitieux que le
président d'edf a confirmé ce matin
devant les sénateurs
mais les finances du groupe pose la
question de leur faisabilité
la dette s'élève à 37 milliards d'euros
et pour l'instant rien ne laisse
présager un avenir plus radieux pour
l'entreprise mais le pdg d'edf se montre
ferme quand il s'agit dink les 'points
j'aurais vous dire que le report d'un
club heinze ne me semble pas opportun
certains évoquent la possibilité de
reporter le projet après la mise en
service de flamanville et de taishan
et ce n'est à mes yeux ni nécessaire ni
faisable
et pourtant le père de flamanville
piétine et l'action d'edf a chuté de
moitié alors faudra-t-il augmenter les
prix de l'électricité un scénario
inenvisageable imaginez le gouvernement
augmente les prix les prix et à dire les
tarifs réglementés
que va faire le consommateur le client
il va quitter ses tarifs réglementés
pour aller sur le marché
à la question des finances s'ajoute
celle de la sûreté récemment ségolène
royal a indiqué vouloir étendre
périmètre de sécurité autour des
centrales de 10 à 20 km cette zone vise
à protéger la population les biens et
l'environnement en cas d'incident
nucléaire
on voit bien dans quel état est de
l'entreprise edf vous autant que mr par
exemple si on augmenter les tarifs d'edf
quelle serait votre réaction
à votre avis je ne sais pas votre avis -
qui fait en sorte depuis que je suis
maire de ne pas augmenter les impôts
locaux et je ne le fais pas malgré les
contraintes de dépenses en moins
demandés par l'état pour l'effort
collectif
évidemment non mais vous voyez la
réserve apple fallait au secours de
grands entreprises françaises il faut
être d'une grande
j'ai même un de nos grands fleurons donc
il faut que l'état
il était monté au créneau plus de 3000
et l'état est actionnaire majoritaire
donc il faut renflouer le capital de ce
que je comprends mais il faut aussi
regarder que edf à 37 milliards
aujourd'hui
la dette est un investissement sur un
plan à 2035 qui s'élève à 100 milliards
sans oublier le ronflement aussi d'areva
qui sera à venir sur c'est plusieurs
milliards je crois que certains
l'estiment à 10 ou 11 milliards de da
d'argent qui affola retrouver pour que
tout ça soit dans une équation équilibré
et que ça ne viennent pas pénaliser
l'usagé donc moi je fais confiance pour
le coup au pdg d'edf confiance aussi à
l'état actionnaire
il faut laisser en cette matière là
celles et ceux qui sont à la commande de
faut pas venir parasiter ce chemin qui
est en train d'être trouvée edf doit
investir en angleterre doit construire
les réacteurs d'une cape comme c'était
prévu 23 milliards d'euros ce contrat
oui en même temps il faut confirmer
fessenheim bas voilà il ya fleurier les
dommages edf dit on y est donc je peux
rappeler de l'accord pas en 2012 avec
les verts bien sûr et est responsable
aussi des relations avec les élus je
suis la politique je le suis à nouveau
voilà meka sms depuis le 9 avril dernier
ce qui est un ancien les relations
extérieures
donc oui je me rappelle de tout cela
mais il va c'est là où je parle de
l'équation un médiateur qui a été nommé
pour voir la compensation à devoir
obtenir pour edf
encore une fois c'est un de nos fleurons
il faut pas qu'on s'engage sur du tout
et son contraire et c'est pour ça qu'on
a nommé monsieur les virées tête
autre sujet vous
les présenter une proposition de loi
demandant votre groupe ce sera le 10 mai
prochain une proposition de loi pour
lutter contre le tabac oui il s'agit en
fait d'imposer des quotas au pays sur la
consommation des particuliers puisque
vous nous expliquer la philosophie de
votre proposition déjà pour ses grandes
lignes
pour celles et ceux qui nous regardent
ils disent une directive mondiale par
l'office mondiale de la santé qui date
du 30 novembre 2015 et qui a été repris
par les deux chambres là aussi au
parlement qui qui dit quoi ces
directives
en gros que pour lutter contre
finalement une forme de commerce
parallèle des cigarettes dans le monde
organisé par les cigarettes a fait que
même si 1000 milliards six mille
milliards de cigarettes produites à
l'année sur les 6000 milliards chiffres
de l' oms 12% sont re router par les
cigarettiers main sur du commerce
parallèle de manière encore plus
exacerbée quand on est en zone
frontalière puisque les prix les taxes
ne sont pas les mêmes
vous voyez ce qui est en train de se
mettre en oeuvre sur du trafic et donc
la hausse des quotas permettrait de
réguler rassoit les quotas déjà demandé
au gouvernement de prendre le décret de
la directive kg l'homme qui l'a toujours
et toujours pas faire il n'a toujours
pas été pris qui bout quoi aussi ce
décret m'a demandé ça la technostructure
qui qui ce décret dit aussi que la
traçabilité du paquet neutre
cigarettiers peut pas être juge et
partie est faite par un organisme
indépendant et moi ce que je souhaite
c'est dans ce projet de loi renforcer
cette directive en imposant des quotas
et on revient à la question vous me
posiez qui permettrait de fournir dans
chaque pays la communauté européenne
le stocks équivalent à la consommation
domestique et non pas un stock
inférieurs parce que là aussi c'est
organiser ce qui permet sur les réseaux
transfrontaliers de faire ce commerce
parallèle que je vous évoquez les
concours donne moins donc il faut
consommer sco ce dont on a besoin et les
cigarettiers organise cela de données -
su par rapport à la consommation
domestique que l'on sait mesurer avec
l'om secrètement comment on les fixe ses
quotas est ce que c'est à l'état de le
faire concrètement les fixes je pense
avec le ms avec l'europe
on collecte par mon collègue l'epargne
oki député européen qui est très alerte
sur le sujet est un bon relais de la
question tout cela doit se faire en
bonne intelligence
encore une fois ça n'a d'intérêt que
pour ramener trois milliards aussi
d'euros dans les caisses de l'état parce
que ce commerce parallèle 3 milliards
d'euros est un trou de 3 milliards et ça
renvoie 250 millions d'euros de perdus
chaque année pour nos 26 bis le
buraliste et j simplement que les
buralistes en france ils sont à 42 %
dans des communes de moins de 3500
habitants et au moment où il crée des
maisons eux mêmes des services publics
dans leurs locaux ils deviennent le
premier voire le seul relais de
proximité
ben moi je me résous pas à les voir
mettre la clé sous le paillasson et à et
à laisser les bras ballants ce commerce
s'organisant par alain bolduc arruda si
cette proposition de loi n'est pas
accepté par vos troupes qu'est-ce qui se
passe en tout cas je moi je suis
légitimiste suivi ce prêt en mon groupe
socialiste je veux en parler avec le
groupe convaincre mon groupe pour cette
ppl soit déposée après qu'est-ce qui se
passe j'espère que le débat fera que
j'aurais emporter le morceau d'accord
donc on en reparlera voilà aux alentours
du 10 mai c'est bien d'arrêter tâche est
grande date du 10 mai au passage jeudi
les opposants à la loi elle comme riz
manifester
nouvelle journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme du travail des manifestations
ont eu lieu dans toutes les villes de
france en marge des cortèges de violents
affrontements ont éclaté alors à paris
notamment marseille où 90 124 personnes
ont été interpellées dans tout le pays
24 policiers et gendarmes ont été
blessés dont un très grièvement à paris
alors luc carvounas les organisateurs se
sont laissés déborder comme le
sous-entend le ministre de l'intérieur
galvanisateur malheureusement raison bah
oui sont les sites débordés suffit de
regarder ce qui se passe chaque soir
quand il lève le camp comme on dit
d'autres préparent un autre camp et
j'entendais ce matin même sur une onde
radio qu'ils s'organisent les policiers
étaient effarés de voir ce que sous les
tentes changer de vêtements ceux qui
justement même des exactions pour se
faufiler dans la population qui sont des
citoyennes et citoyens qui a envie de se
retrouver
j'ai envie de discuter j'ai cru
comprendre c'est mais j'y suis allé un
très objectivement je devais de vous
parler mais c'est un c'est un tout il ya
de lui debout il ya les manifestations
etc aubry c'est la même chose mais
debout et les casas et des activistes
gauchiste mais bien sûr pour ceux qui
cassent à la fin de nuit debout et ceux
qui se retrouvent dans les dents les
manifestations d'alwan conneries on voit
bien que nos jeunes cerveaux comme a dit
nicolas sarkozy n'aurait peut-être pas
jusque là parce que nicolas sarkozy est
un habitué de l'outrance verbale et du
mépris du citoyen en général
non mais que ce soit sur les lois là les
manifestants la loi travail et les
débordements gauchistes autour ou ce que
je vous dis sur ce qui se passe tous les
soirs à nuit debout
ce sont à peu près les mêmes et les
mêmes corpus est ce que les syndicats
doivent condamner les violences comme
bien sûr qu'ils le doivent enfin
j'espère que tout républicain condamne
les violences encore une fois manifesté
cet endroit et enfonce on n'a même pas
l'état d'urgence et en france on a même
le droit de manifester pendant un état
d'urgence
donc c'est formidable vous voyez la
démocratie que nous sommes qu'à partir
d'abobo ça doit sur l'état d'urgence je
le dis on c'est pas cela nous un danger
plus belles manifestations l'état
d'urgence a été mis en place pour
renforcer les pouvoirs de police et de
justice par rapport au terrorisme pas
que la légende urbaine d'empêcher des
manifestations dans tous les cas
aujourd'hui
il faut condamner très fermement très
durement toutes celles et tous ceux qui
que ce soit dans le cadre de
protestation qu'on doit entendre la loi
travail ou que ce soit dans le cadre de
mouvements citoyens intéressant qu'il
faut regarder j'y suis allé pour nuit
debout on peut pas autoriser que cela
vienne tout dévoyé il faut interdire
nuit debout
non il faut de route devra quand même
du coup moi j'ai l'impression ça j'y
suis allé une fois les rencontrer au
tout début
abbas que c'est cette jeunesse pas
forcément tout jeune âge jeunesse qui
est un peu le miroir de notre jeunesse
plus réactionnaires qui s'étaient
rassemblés pour la manif pour tous donc
moi j'entends ce j'entends nos jeunes
qui s'interrogent sur leur avenir je le
méprise pas moi même ma première manif
temps 86 j'avais 15 ans et contre
devaquet donc faut pas mépriser ces
mouvements citoyens mais faut pas non
plus en faire l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
action politique présente et à venir
vous parler de la ville travaille
d'abord peut-être est-ce que vous
imaginez que le gouvernement puisse
sortir l'arbre vous savez cette fameuse
arme de 49 3 c'est visiblement ça a
quand même très compliqué mais vos corps
de la faire passer à l'assemblée
nationale je serais assez étrange
puisque entre le moment où il ya cette
indiscrétion dans le journal le monde la
décision du premier ministre
d'interrompre pendant quinze jours pour
pouvoir de discuter avec l'ami du
travail et le texte qui est encore en
discussion je vois le rapporteur sirugue
notamment sur des questions comme le cd
détaxés pas taxées mais je vois le
bureau national qui quasi unanimement et
compris les collègues qui sont pourtant
généralement la voix des frondeurs de
considérer qu'il a vu de belles avancées
de fait après je voudrais qu'on
m'explique pourquoi des députés de
gauche n'irait pas voter un texte qui
sanctuarisent salah le cdi
oui mais général jusqu'à présent nos
textes passent mais sur un texte aussi
symbolique je ne souhaite pas moi je
suis sénateur le texte arrivera aussi
notre plus tard que le 49-3 soit employé
à l'assemblée nationale vous êtes ces
dates heures et il s'est passé quelque
chose cette semaine c'est que le sénat a
décidé de saisir la justice
ça y est golog qui est soupçonnée
d'avoir menti sous serment devant une
commission denquête c'était la
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
la pollution de l'air il aurait caché
ses liens avec l'industrie pétrolière
quant à kamel vous explique tout cela on
en revient donc discuter dans un instant
c'est une décision inédite est prise ce
matin à l'unanimité des membres du
bureau du sénat
ce dernier estime que la déclaration
sous serment du professeur aubier devant
la commission denquête le 16 avril 2015
selon laquelle il n'avait aucun lien
d'intérêt avec les acteurs économiques
pouvaient apparaître mensongère
mensongère car le professeur aubier
auditionné sur la question de la
pollution de l'air en tant que
représentant de l'assistance publique
les hôpitaux de paris était au même
moment salariés par total mais devant
les sénateurs le médecin ne mentionne
pas cette information alors même que la
question lui est directement posée miss
le biais qui lors de cette audition
minimise l'impact du diesel sur la santé
publique expliquant que le nombre de
cancers dans les pathologies
respiratoires liées à la pollution de
l'air est extrêmement faible pour les
laïcs qui avait auditionné le professeur
oublier la saisine du parquet est une
excellente nouvelle
je salue cette décision parce que le
mensonge du professeur aux vielles lors
d'une commission denquête est un grave
et grave pourquoi parce que la question
qui nous concerne est qui préoccupait
c'était une question de santé publique
puisqu'il s'agissait d'une commission d'
enquête sur le coût économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air et
qu'il a menti à une commission denquête
là au sein de la représentation
nationale et que de fait il a menti aux
français le professeur aubier encourt
jusqu'à 75000 euros d'amendé et cinq ans
d'emprisonnement
voilà en fait quand même c'est une
décision historique de la part du bureau
du sénat qui a décidé de saisir la
justice
ou bien que vous saluer la décision
version du sénat estimez-vous que
l'institution a été lésé dans cette
affaire ça c'est la justice qui le dira
apps on le sait le borussia n'a dit si
de saisir la justice mais en tous les
cas vous le savez j'ai écrit un livre
sur les institutions je pense que il
faut que les institutions que les
commissions permanentes que lorsque l'on
aditionne sous serment que chacun
reprenne les règles rôle de ce que l'on
doit de ce qui se doit et donc cela
participe aussi à à revenir en lien avec
nos concitoyens qui ne croient plus à la
politique a pas de moment où quelque
chose qui ne convient pas qu'il ne
fonctionne pas le bureau et qui eut un
mensonge visiblement le bureau a eu
raison de saisir et mieux que vous
parlez des institutions vous avez
peut-être vu ce sondage cette semaine où
des sénateurs les députés
plus du tout la confiance des citoyens
le maire reste encore vous le savez très
bien le reste plus mais reste en tête
que ce soit le parlementaire au sénat et
assemblée puis de lire il ya plus de
conférence mais c'est presque normal
j'ai envie de vous dire entre
l'assemblée nationale nous avions de
l'or entre les mains la gauche nous
dirigions ce pays nous dirigeons encore
et nous avons offert un spectacle
finalement de division tout gauche
confondues d'où la nécessité de cette
pédagogie qu'on évoquait au tout début
de l'émission il faut commencer à faire
l'inventaire
je suis au canada bien sûr c'est très
important de faire un vrai inventaire
mais qui vaut aussi pour nos partenaires
qui nous ont abandonné en rase campagne
pas un inventaire entre socialistes que
le pc les écologistes qui dirige comme
alfortville la commune avec moi le
département ensemble du val de marne où
la région nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
l'opposition ensemble qui nous disent
pourquoi malgré le contrat de
gouvernement que nous avons mené
ensemble ya quelques années ils ont
rompu ce contrat il suffira pas de me
dire celle cice c'est l'histoire du
discours notre ennemi c'est la finance
ça sera un peu léger donc cette
introspection
on l'a tous intérêt à la faire et c'est
pour moi la seule le seul socle qui
pourra nous relégitimer tous ensemble
parce que moi je souhaite que il fit
nous repartions tous ensemble pour
pouvoir justement éviter que ne vienne
demain une droite que j'appelle que j'ai
appelé avec le bar tenu par la campagne
ile-de-france cette droite
cette droite dure vous avez fait des
erreurs comme le constate manuel valls
dans le magazine society aujourd'hui
vous fait des erreurs pendant quatre
semaines à la gauche a fait des erreurs
en tous les cas je pense oui on
s'entraide on fait des erreurs pour
avoir un tel niveau de défiance alors
que notre action si elle avait été plus
lisible n'aurait pas dû aider q comme ça
mais après vous savez le peuple français
c'est un peu pour selon moi très
politique il suffit pas à même d'avoir
un très bon bilan souvient de 2002
lionel jospin
donc c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes investies les maires et nous
sommes investies les parlementaires pour
faire juste en sorte qu'un truc hein que
la gauche puisse enfin
assumer son rapport au pouvoir c'est ça
aussi une interview dreux donald balzan
social justement voir c'est l'exercice
du pouvoir de la gauche manuel valls on
en reparle avec notre partenaire la
loupe du scan gym jarrassé nous a
rejoint
bonjour j'ai déjà assez pour bonjour
nasa alors justement vous avez ok cette
interview de manuel valls antonetti qui
sort aujourd'hui
il liste les erreurs du quinquennat il
parle de de l'antisarkozysme que que la
gauche a mis en avant comme seul ressort
au début du quinquennat il dit on n'a
pas suffisamment assumé le vit le virage
économique et sécuritaire
un droit d'inventaire fait par le
premier ministre a un nom de la fin du
quinquennat est ce que c'est une bonne
méthode
oui il est dans son rôle si le chef de
la majorité
il a été mis là par le président de la
république pour à la fois animer cette
majorité puis mettre en place la
politique voulue par le président de la
république celle pour laquelle il a été
élu le 6 mai 2012 où il est dans son
rôle et il est dans son discours de
vérité que je lui ai toujours connu
avoir c'est de dire les choses de les
nommer et on a vraiment un complexe nous
la gauche on me le disait avant de
gagner le 6 mai 2012
moi ça vous avez dix ans 80 donc j'ai
pas connu comme d'autres cette première
victoire
on disait tu vas voir la gauche on a un
complexe dans le rapport au pouvoir je
voulais pas y croire parce que moi je
suis de la génération qui avait gagné
toutes les élections intermédiaires et
donc je les lis pas possible pas avoir
gagné toutes les villes les départements
les régions et avoir un complexe de
rapport au pouvoir quand on va diriger
le pays et c'est malheureusement ce qui
s'est produit est ce que pour manuel
valls est pas finalement un moyen de
ceux de prendre un peu de distance avec
ce quinquennat pour ceux déjà se placer
dans l' après 2017
est ce que vous croyez que c'est le rôle
du
chef de la majorité de se placer dans la
presse moi j'ai toujours entendu et je
fais partie de ceux qui sait ce qu'il
ressent c'est ce qui semble se remet
néanmoins ce que je sais de lui c'est
qu'on parlait des institutions c'est
qu'il a chevillé au corps justement de
nos institutions et leur fonctionnement
savez même à moi qui suis un de ses
proches il ne m'avait jamais les
échanges qu'il a avec le président de la
république parce que ce ne sont pas des
échanges à 2000m les échanges entre le
président république et son premier
ministre
et donc si je dis cela c'est que quand
on parlait du rapport à la fidélité de
cette culture politique qui m'a été
éduqué quand on parlait des modèles
mâcon vis-à-vis de françois hollande
manuel valls est un homme extrêmement
loyale est extrêmement fidèle à celui
qui lui a fait confiance en le nommant
au poste jusqu'au il a nommé lattes et
après écoutez moi j'ai été le directeur
de campagne de manuel valls aux
premières primaires citoyennes et
républicaines en 2011
et moi j'ai toujours vu en manuel valls
notre candidat pour être j'espère en
2022 prison la république mais pour moi
cette étape j'ai toujours dit passait
par la réélection de françois hollande
si tenté qu'il soit qu'ils soient
candidats puisqu'il a su jti un critère
important sur la baisse du chômage
dans tous les cas j'ai toujours été
clair 2022 donc ça reste l'objectif
mais pour ça il faut qu'on réussisse
2017 parce que si on perd 2017
la gauche va même plus explosé elle va
imploser on va avoir beaucoup parce que
nous le ps on impose peut-être le
regarder ce qui se passe chez
écologistes chez les communistes ou
ironie et rapide gauche et est ce que le
risque pour manuel valls et pas de
suivre un peu la trajectoire de françois
fillon qui a fini son passage à matignon
très abîmé qui encore aujourd'hui dans
la compétition pour la primaire
comptable du bilan du princess du
précédent quinquennat reste que c'est un
risque
c'est la première fois qu'on me compare
aussi ouvertement habituellement
vous pouvez aussi me le comparer à un
jacques chirac a été produit nice et qui
est devenu président de la république
voilà donc moi je sais pas quelles sont
ce type de comparaison tant que je vois
pas comment se déroule la fin de ce
quinquennat
d'ailleurs françois fillon même lui même
candidat aux primaires à droite pour
être candidat est élu président en 2017
faut arrêter de se comparer les uns et
les autres parce que du coup à force de
se comparer les uns les autres
ça laisse entendre même à des gens
brillants qui a ni de gauche ni de
droite le fait est que malgré le fait
est que manuel valls est dans une
mauvaise passe en termes de popularité
en semant regarder cette courbe cette
enquête harris qui vient de sortir on
voit que la cour de manuel valls
continue de baisser alors que celle de
françois hollande remonte légèrement ils
sont plus qu'à quatre points d'écart
dans les sondages
est ce que le premier ministre peut
finir le quinquennat moins populaire que
le président de la république
écoutez le premier ministre quand il a
accepté cette mission après une débâcle
municipal il l'a fait ce pari audacieux
que pour une la première fois peut-être
le tandem président la république
premier ministre pouvait être un tandem
qui se fasse marche pied l'un l'autre et
que ce soit un couple sans une feuille
de papier entre l'un est lourd ni
présent la république remonte dans les
sondages tant mieux premier ministre
baisse un peu dans les sondages pas dans
ce moment là
je le déplore a je me batte avec
d'autres pour que les choses changent
dans tous les cas il n'y a pas de y'a
pas regarder encore une fois l'un est
avec l'hôte et l'un va avec l'autre et
ce qui peut faire pour se relancer on
sait que chaque été il a l'habitude de
prononcer un discours à ses personnels à
ces politiques à vauvert notamment
est-ce que vous l'appelez à faire la
même chose cette année un an de la
présidentielle à se dévoiler encore il
ya des choses que je comprends pas on
nous on nous dit que la croissance
premier trimestre et au delà des
espérances même si certains de + 0 1
on voit qu il ya moins soixante mille
chômeurs de moins on voit que la
croissance est là le pouvoir d achat des
ménages repart et malgré ça j'entends
qu'est ce que manuel valls doit faire
pour se relancer mais se relancer sur
quoi sur la politique il en train de me
dis qu'est en train de réussir cette qui
est l'exemple du tandem hollande valls
france françois hollande et son premier
ministre vous maintenant aller jusqu'au
bout de ce quinquennat sur les réformes
pour lesquelles ils ont été mandatés
n'attendez pas de moi de vous sortir il
n'y aura pas de rôles à gauche
valls il y aura par ailleurs à ba2 en
marche
on n'a jamais fait de courant nous nous
notre famille
question quel parti socialiste est ce
qu'il doit continuer à parler d'identité
manuel valls on l'a entendu parler du
voile comme un signe d'asservissement
d'affirmer que le salafisme étaient en
train de gagner la bataille dans les
banlieues c'est des termes assez fort
qui ont été parfois un peu critiqué par
certains de vos camarades social que sk
ou en banlieue
monsieur non bon moi je vis en banlieue
j'y suis né je suis même devenu le maire
de la ville de banlieue je suis né donc
je comprends très bien ce qui est en
train de dire manuel valls sur le
salafiste dans les salles de prière qui
est en train de s'installer mais aussi
parce qu'il ya dans certaines villes de
banlieue une fois que je le dis ici de
complaisance de ce que j'appelle le
premier guichet républicains que sont
les maires parce que ça les arrange de
banias électoraliste alliot marie
lemoine l'islamo gauchisme c'est un
terrain tout l'éclat reprenait je laisse
à jean marie le guen ses propos en tous
les cas je comprends très bien ce que
manuel valls décrit lui qui a été maire
d'une ville de banlieue que moi et qui a
vécu longtemps donc
encore une fois il faut manipuler les
termes avec beaucoup d'intelligence moi
vous savez sur le voile là aussi je dis
faisait intentions ou mots parce que
l'islam pour moi les généraux marine le
pen dit quand tu entends manuel valls
parler d'islam j'ai l'impression de me
lire oui mais marion deux semaines je
pense qu'elle ferait bien de nous dire
où il en est dans sa tête parce qu'elle
est dans un délire total
juste merci avant de quitter ici mais
vous aviez accusé le président du sénat
je cite des partial lors des questions
d'actualité de privilégier un peu la
droite écoutez ce qu'il vous réponde est
totalement faux j'ai fait un petit
statistiques que j'ai rapporté il ya
trois semaines en conférence des
présidents
la différence entre socialistes et
républicains ces 52 centièmes de seconde
pendant trois mois vous rendez compte
monsieur carvounas et sensible c'est un
sprinteur et même les communistes ont
dépassé de 8 secondes 16 des écologistes
de 7 secondes pour en déco monsieur
carvounas il faut qu'il reprenne son
cours de m vous avez repris votre rôle
de m j'ai appris mon chrono m et puis
vous savez dans la gestuelle quand on a
les bras fermé c'est que on est fermé à
la question c'est psychologique de la
gestuelle et puis moi je plains le
collaborateur de cabinet grand des
comptes mandaté par gérard larcher quand
j'en ai parlé qui a dû regarder trois
mois précédents pour le venue au
centième près donc son chrono guette ces
luttes il invente mais si on a des
problèmes de comptage pour des photos au
moment des jo on va demander à son
collaborateur
kevin est donné le mettre en détachement
à paris et bordeaux fera passer le
message
merci beaucoup lui car oui nas merci
d'avoir été ainsi leur diversité
parlement hebdo c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis très bonne journée à tous sur les
chaînes parlementaires